and then the boy begins dancing through
the house and uh he's at one point he's
smearing paint on the walls kicking over
lamps
uh he knocks over his sister's paints
and he spills them on the carpet he
throws glitter all over the living room
and then you see at one point is his
mother is looking on with a blank
expression and then the ad ends with the
words let life happen
home insurance so that's the ad before
we even get to the issue of the buoyant
address i think there are a number of
basic concept problems with this ad the
first is that no insurance company on
earth i can tell you this right now
including john lewis i'm quite sure will
cover damage to your home which has been
caused intentionally by your bratty
child the real point is that the
marketing agency that made this ad went
out and hired a young boy dressed them
up in makeup and heels and told him to
dance around the house while they film
him
why
well because the people behind this ad
are a bunch of creepy disgusting freaks
and like all the other creepy disgusting
freaks who run our culture they really
want your child to be gender fluid